okay
uh
um
the rally started
hey i'm gonna do audio checks one two
one two you guys okay back there
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
got me okay you're right back there ed
or is anyone
you okay one two one two
i know okay thanks
right do you need to focus on
you good
waiting at home
um
okay
you never know
okay
you need a focus handle yes please
all right
okay
is
yes
uh
i think
you come here
every time
again
okay
um
okay
his attention
hey
all right
thank you
foreign
oh
thank you
sorry about that
i'm good
right
oh
um yeah
sure
so
yes sir
uh
is
you
you
years we are expecting him to comment on
the charges of the brianna taylor case
and the violence that we've seen
gripping the streets of louisville the
president was asked about it earlier
today
in the cabinet room that hadn't been
briefed up enough on it to feel
comfortable
commenting on the president also
expected to be asked this evening
about his looming pick for the supreme
court earlier today
the president pointing to his favorite
boogeyman mail in voting
is a reason to quickly return the
supreme court to its full strength
you
president trump might get some more love
from hispanics if it were to nominate
barbara lego from the olympic circuit
court of appeals to fill the seat
vacated by ruth vader ginsburg but with
only a year's worth of experience
on the federal bench there are concerns
among some people
that lagoa's judicial record is a little
thin so for the moment breath tonight
baby coney barrett remains the front
uh
you
um
two minute warning
okay
wait
what
so
all right
hello thank you very much thank you
today johnson and johnson announced that
their vaccine candidate has reached the
final stage of clinical trials this is
record time
this is the fourth vaccine candidate in
the united states to reach the final
stage of trial so we have four
candidates already at a very
late date late being a very positive
word in this case
earlier this year johnson and johnson
anticipated that they would reach phase
one trials by september but due to our
support
under operation warp speed and to
some of the incredible scientists
involved they've reached
phase three trials by september far
ahead of schedule
we encourage americans to enroll in the
vaccine trial
it's not only interesting it'll be
terrific thing for our country we
encourage everybody to enroll as many
people as
we can today my administration announced
that we are
awarding 200 million dollars of cares
act funding
to all 50 states to prepare to
distribute the vaccine
to high-risk residents and we want to do
that
the instant it is approved not the
following day but the following moment
and so we're going to be doing that and
we'll be distributing getting it ready
because we have some
great vaccines going to be coming out
through operation warp speed
we also continue to accelerate
life-saving
therapies we're seeing promising results
that are
monoclonal antibody treatments which
help
the immune system fight the virus and
help very significantly refining can
reduce hospitalizations now by more than
70 percent
by cutting red tape and then leaching
america's medical genius we've reduced
the fatality
rate 85 since april for individuals
under 50
they've they have a 99.98
rate of survival from the china virus
that's a number that's been in
really increasing substantially with
time
as children go back to school we're
encouraged that early
research shows only a small degree of
spread
brown university conducted a study of
more than 550 schools across 46 states
and found that only 0.076 percent of
students
had confirmed cases of the virus that's
a tiny
percentage and only 0.15 percent of
teachers had
confirmed cases patients coming to the
emergency room due to the virus
is down to only 1.6 percent of all
emergency room
visits the lowest since the pandemic
began
1.6 emergency room
visits as far as
protecting the vulnerable is concerned
we provided over 21 billion dollars
to our nursing homes and we are really
focused on the nursing homes everybody
including
our governors we have governors are
working very closely with the
task force with the vice president and
everybody involved we've sent
rapid testing devices to nearly 14 000
certified nursing homes
in the country this week we're sending
hundreds of thousands of additional
rapid tests to nursing homes to ensure
they can
test staff regularly
and the staff now is being tested on a
very very powerful and
on a regular basis but very strongly at
the finest level the highest level
on the best tests we're encouraged that
the number of americans getting the flu
vaccine is increasing by roughly 50
percent compared to last year
substantially up the flu when it's mixed
with
covid or china virus is uh
going to be very interesting to see what
happens but that can drive
numbers and we just don't know what that
will be yet but you'll have flu numbers
and you'll have some covet numbers
i think we're rounding the turn very
much you see what's happening in europe
however they have a
very big spike countries that we thought
were doing well aren't doing well they
had some
very big spikes very a very big surge
months ago we increased our nation's
procurement
of the flu vaccine by 66 and we asked
americans to go get their annual flu
shot
as early as possible it's possible i
would imagine
scott that the flu can get mixed up with
the virus and people can think it's the
virus when actually it's another flu
season coming on
i don't know it's uh i hope they can
keep them separate can they keep them
separate
we hope so i can't they will it's
going to be a very interesting time but
we have a flu season coming up we've had
some flu seasons which are
really massive over the years over many
years and some that are
much less so but it's still significant
so i hope they can
separate them because it's it's pretty
close
in the past four months we've created
10.6 million jobs
we cut unemployment rate nearly in half
the unemployment rate has cut nearly in
half larry kudlow is here he'll be
discussing that in a little while
retail sales are up 121
that's far above what we thought
manufacturing is up 61
that's also above our schedule and our
schedule is a
heavy schedule automobile production is
up
six fold homebuilders sentiment is at
the highest level in history
that's an amazing statement larry the
highest level in history that means
people are thinking
good thoughts home sales are at the
highest level
in nearly 15 years small business
optimism is higher than any time
under the last administration
substantially higher small business
optimism
higher than at any time over the last
more than
the last administration today i was
proud to award nine companies and
organizations with the first ever pledge
to america's workers presidential award
this
award recognizes outstanding training
programs that are
giving americans the skills to hone a
trade and earn a great living
great people over 400 companies have
competed and
committed to 16 million training
opportunities for the american worker
and it's really been amazing we've
created the fastest economic recovery in
american history
you are witnessing it you're part of it
our approach is pro
science biden's approach is anti-science
if you look it's
i don't think they know what their
approach is although a lot of us copied
from what we've done
biden opposed the china travel ban the
europe travel ban
and the strategy that they have is just
never ending
lockdowns we're not locking down we're
actually growing at a rate that we've
never experienced before
but they're talking about if you have a
question just lock it down we're not
doing that
and you can't do that our plan will
crush the virus and
actually biden's plan will crush america
if you think about it you can't lock
down
again we're growing at levels that
nobody's ever seen before our planet is
unleashing a rapid recovery our
opponent's plan
would hurt america very badly send us
into a depression
and uh with all of that being said
we are going to be having a very
exciting
saturday at five o'clock in the rose
garden where i'll be putting forth
my nominee for supreme court justice
and i think it will be a a great nominee
brilliant nominee as you know it's
a woman we've brought it down to five
women
it's time for a woman to uh
to be chosen with everything that's
happened
and with justice ginsburg's passing
we are going to go sometime tomorrow
morning as i understand it
to pay our respects and we'll be over
there and i guess they probably put that
announcement down
that'll be done tomorrow morning the
vice president was there today
and so uh if you have any questions
we'll take a few questions
right here mr president uh real quickly
when loser draw in this election will
you commit here today
for a peaceful trans uh referral of
power after the election
and there has been writing in louisville
there's been rioting in many cities
across this country
red and your so-called red and blue
states will you commit to making sure
that there is a peaceful transferal of
power after the election
well we're gonna have to see what
happens you know that i've been
complaining very strongly about
the ballots and the ballots are a
disaster
but people are writing do you commit to
making sure that there's a peaceful
transfer we want to get rid of the
ballots and you'll have a very trans
we'll have a very peaceful
there won't be a transfer frankly
there'll be a continuation
the ballots are out of control you know
it and you know who knows it better than
anybody else the democrats know it
better than anybody else
the second question is
i'm sorry uh do you plan to meet with
barbara lego in washington and
is she still on your short list she is
on my list i don't have a
meeting planned uh but she is on my list
i don't really talk about the media's
plan i i speak to people i talk to
people
but i don't have a meeting plan do you
uh have a response to the governor of
missouri
uh testing positive for corona virus
i didn't know that no yeah
mr president um
we asked you earlier today about uh the
briana taylor case yes can you
comment now i assume you've been briefed
on the charges in the book
really brilliant conduct attorney
general daniel cameron is doing a
fantastic job i think he's a star
and he made a statement that i'll just
read
[Music]
justice not justice is not often easy
it does not fit the mold of public
opinion and it does not conform
to shifting standards it ends only to
the facts
and to the law if we simply act on
emotion or outrage there's no justice
mob justice is not justice
justice sought by violence is not
justice
it just becomes revenge i mean i did
that
down from me please because i think it's
it was a terrific statement
he's handling it very well you know who
he is
you i think you know i think everyone
now knows who he is
i will be speaking to the governor and
uh
we have a call scheduled to make very
shortly
the governor i understand he's called up
the national guard which is
a good thing i think it's a very
positive thing and
it'll all work out
[Music]
it's highly unlikely that any democrats
will vote for your nominee
uh if it when it comes to a vote in in
the senate i don't know
given the posture i think that's a
pretty safe assumption
but on that point would you want to
nominate someone who in their
confirmation to the appellate court
received broad bipartisan support or
would you be more inclined to put
forward somebody
whose confirmation fell along party
lines
i can't tell you what's going to happen
with the democrats i can say this
the person that i will be putting up and
i won't say that i've even chosen that
person yet i could say any one of the
five they're outstanding women
but the person i'll be putting up is
highly qualified
totally brilliant top of the line
academic
student highest credentials all of them
have that but
the highest credentials and you'll see
on saturday who that is i can't imagine
why a democrat wouldn't vote for this
person
probably better than you yeah please go
ahead thank you very much
no i didn't like you thank you mr
president uh prince harry and meghan
markle
uh chimed in on the us election and
essentially encouraged people to vote
for dividends
let me get the reaction to that i'm not
a fan of hers and
uh i would say this
and she probably has heard that but uh
i wish a lot of luck to harry
because she's gonna need it mr president
the fda is reportedly considering
stricter guidelines
for the emergency authorization of a
copa vaccine
are you okay with that well i tell you
what we're looking at that that has to
be approved by the white house we may or
may not approve it
uh that sounds like a political move
because when you have pfizer johnson and
johnson
modern are these great companies coming
up with these the vaccines and they've
done testing and everything else
i'm saying why would they have to be you
know adding
great length to the process we want to
have people not get sick
the vaccine is very important it's the
final step i believe it's going to be
the final step
and no we're looking at that but i think
it's a i think that was a political move
more than anything else
it's designed to
improve trust in the vaccine do you
think that's not needed
well i have tremendous trust in these
massive
companies that are so brilliantly
organized in terms of what they've been
doing with the tests i mean
i don't know that a government as big as
we are could do tests like this we've
made it possible for them to do the test
in rapid fashion
but when they come back and they say
that we have something that
works and absolutely works and they're
coming back with great numbers and
statistics and tests and everything else
that they have to come back with
i don't see any reason why it should be
delayed further because
if they delete delay in a week or two
weeks or three weeks
you know that's a lot of lives you're
talking about scott would you agree with
that or how do you feel about that
yeah thanks um yeah i mean there is no i
think that people don't understand
what's going on with operation warp
speed
it's unprecedented what's happened here
a typical vaccine takes roughly four
years or so
and now we're going to have a vaccine
highly likely in far less than one year
but without cutting any safety corners
because the president has
done things contaminant to the
development of the vaccine that is the
manufacturing the logistics
everything is being done at the same
time and that's never been done before
but there is zero cutting of safety
concerns there is there should be no
uh hesitation about the safety you
shouldn't be punished by doing something
faster than other people
could have done or thought it's the
opposite we have a pandemic
the urgency is the pandemic not politics
are you a man extremely political why
would they do this when we come back
and ultimately the white house has to
approve it and
maybe we will but we'll be taking a look
i have to leave for an emergency phone
call i'm going to let scott
and larry finish that larry's going to
talk about it
so i'll be uh i'll be back i will see
you tomorrow one more question on
brianna taylor we're at a time right now
where
americans feel like we are on this
parent
mr president just one more question if i
can't briana taylor
people are protesting in the streets
what is your message to them people feel
like you're on this carousel we're
another black lives mate so here we have
dr
scott atlas and larry kudlow um i
encourage you all to be respectful and
show a little bit of decorum here as
they take your questions
[Music]
he said to fox in july that when younger
healthier people get the disease they
don't have a problem with the disease
or groups getting the infection is not a
problem in fact it's a positive
can you say what you meant by that is
does that
indicate that oh sure spreading sort of
among younger folks who are less
susceptible no i think i've answered
this multiple times but i have never
advocated a herd immunity strategy
there's never been
a desire to have cases spread through
the community
that's a false story i've denied that
multiple times
and i just don't that false story
doesn't seem to die
but that's the fact and the description
of immunity coming when people get an
infection
is not something i'm inventing that but
that has never been a policy that i have
advocated there has never been a policy
uh recommendation to pursue that
to the president and that is not the
president's policy sixty thousand cases
yesterday do you have any sense or does
the task force have any sense of what is
driving that that's the highest level
in six weeks why are we still seeing
cases at this level
yeah well i mean there are several
things to look at but the case
metric is not the most important metric
the most important metric
are the following hospitalizations per
day are coming down
deaths per day are coming down number of
people in the hospital
is 47 lower than it was since its peak
the number of people sick with coveted
illness coming to the emergency room
is 1.6 percent as the president said the
lowest number
since the pandemic began all of these
trends are positive
the cases per se are defined by tests
if i tested a million people i would see
more cases
the only thing that counts are the the
problems with the cases
so when we see that hospitalizations per
day are coming down
people are not dying as much these are
all very positive trends and that's
exactly what we want to see
go
no i saw the story in uh really a super
journalism story uh the doctor
speaks for herself but that that's a
completely false story and she denied it
today
it's completely false it's been seven
years
when do you expect a vaccine yeah so
this is a very important uh
question the the vaccine is proceeding
at an extremely rapid pace as we know
everything's being done simultaneously
with so that the
logistics and the technology in place to
deliver it is ready to go as everyone
knows
and it depends on the data okay the the
data
is being monitored by an external group
of experts
called the data data safety monitoring
board
and when we have enough cases that when
they see enough cases
that have shown a statistically
significant difference they will tell
the company and then the company
will say look at it and say yes we have
it and we think that that
has a good chance of happening in
october it's kind of just that i follow
you did say that
last week in this room pretty much the
same thing but you said it would be the
truth
well i understand but i want to clear it
up because you said it could be as late
as january it could be after the
election
that there's no clear-cut time and
that's what i want to make sure that
that you're saying this is the current
thinking that i have been told i'm not
in charge of the vaccine development i'm
relaying information
and what i've been told is exactly what
i said and there will be
a hundred million plus doses available
by the end of this year
it is highly likely we will have a
vaccine before the end of the year
and it is also likely that we will say
the data is good we have the vaccine and
then it will be submitted of course for
approval and authorization sometime in
october but it depends on the
on the data no one can really say with
certainty when it's coming that's just
impossible
i don't see the data until the data
happens
dr redfield today said that more than 90
percent of the population remains
susceptible to coronavirus do you agree
with that
yeah i think that dr reckfield uh
misstated something there
and last time i'm going to answer your
question let me finish
the data on susceptible that he was
talking about was his
uh surveillance data that showed that
roughly nine percent of the country
has antibodies but when you look at the
cdc data state by state
much of that data is old some of it goes
back to march or april before many of
these states had the cases
that's point number one point number two
is that the immunity to the infection
is not solely determined by the percent
of people who have antibodies
if you look at the research and there's
been about 24 papers at least
on the immunity from t cells there's
different type of
immunity than antibodies and without
being boring
the reality is that according to the
papers from sweden
singapore and elsewhere there is
cross-immunity
highly likely from other infections and
there is also t-cell immunity and the
combination of those
makes the antibodies a small fraction of
the people that have immunity so the
answer is no
it is not 90 of people that are
susceptible to the infection so i guess
my question is for i'm not a doctor i
defer to your expertise on this end to
his but so americans hear one thing from
the cdc director and another thing from
you
who are we to believe you're supposed to
believe the science and i'm telling you
the science
so he's not telling us i'm telling you
the science and that's the answer and if
you want to look
up all the data you're free to you can
also talk to the following
epidemiologist why is he still going out
before congress and speaking if you say
he's mistaken today and the president
said he mistaken last time americans are
looking for the best information right
yeah and i'm giving you the best
information and it's confirmed by people
like martin koldorf who's a harvard
epidemiologist at harvard medical school
let me finish please
jay bhattacharya and john yanitis both
epidemiologists at stanford
uh professor gupta university of oxford
these are people who know
the latest data on the immunology and
what's happening and i just recite it to
you
i'm going to give scott a little time
off i'm just going to give god a little
time off
i want to reinforce some of the things
that president trump said about the
economy because that's
very much a key part of the story we got
some new numbers out
late last week and this week and i
wanted to underscore that
if we can get the charts back up i want
to show you some more
examples of the d-shaped recovery
actually i i can jump in here this is
from the
census bureau court uh a change in the
number of people living in poverty
um during president trump's uh first
three years
6.6 million uh fewer people
6.6 million fewer people are living in
poverty what's the proposed
and the um what's the number of post
tenants well we'll have to wait and see
on that
would you mark it anymore let me go to
uh years 787 000 people
uh moved into poverty so that's a
problem and we have the second
chart isn't it yeah this is a brand new
this stuff just came out lately
right now if i if i may okay i just like
accurate information
this is the accurate information
this is from the center it's not quite
and it just came back
well let me just go back into this three
years
into president trump's uh presidency
under his policies
real family income is probably the best
measure of living standards there is
real median household income grew by 6
000 over six
thousand dollars that is five times the
rate
of the eight years of the obama
administration
i hear people ask me legitimate
questions i respect that
that this is some kind of has been a
k-shaped recovery
where only the wealthy did well and the
bottom did not do well
in fact this is the middle real family
income and i will add to that not only
was this five times higher
but the biggest gains came in the lower
income levels significantly higher than
the top one percent
uh or the top uh 10 now let me hit
another chart
put this up uh see where we're doing
this
by field go ahead more charts
there we go back to the v-shape recovery
you've heard me speak about this i just
want to underscore
we got new production numbers uh this
week this is a v-shape recovery in
automobiles a key sector of the economy
and we had additional numbers on housing
that i'd like to show
confirming the v-shaped uh recovery
housing housing there we go we're at
all-time high in home builder sentiment
all right very important leading
indicator a clear v-shape recovery and
if anything it's strengthening
and finally i think the last chart is on
home sales here it is
their highest reading in 14 years
so i i just want to say
we have more work to do with respect to
the um
to the recovery and return to economic
health we have more work to do there is
still hardship and there is still
heartbreak
but the numbers coming in how many
americans are living in poverty right
now
actually that won't be that won't be
reported
i can only wait until the census bureau
i don't know if you cover this beat
the number of americans living in
poverty right now do you happen to know
the answer
uh no you don't know i will wait you're
an economic advisor
right if you just stop nitpicking and
let me explain
history well you should have a history
lesson
too it will help you understand but i'm
going to say to you these are
census bureau numbers the most accurate
comprehensive
they are not out yet so i'm giving you
the ones that were released
late last week they're the most up
numbers
and under the president's policies of
lower taxes and regulations and energy
independence
and better trade deals we've had a
phenomenal increase
in living standards five times what the
prior administration had for eight years
and we're proud of that and this is a
topic that will come up again
again second point i want to make is
while living standards went up
poverty went down and inequality went
down
so the notion that under president trump
only the top-end benefit
is simply not true these are facts
from the census bureau and they are
backed up by many other facts that we've
talked about
as i've discussed with those of you and
then finally
the v-shape recovery we've got more work
to do
on unemployment and employment no
question about that
i think this is a self-sustaining
recovery as i've said
we would welcome some additional
assistance in targeted areas
particularly getting back to school and
working on covert related safety
precautions and health precautions
we'd love to see an extension of the
small business loans
the ppp program but the recovery itself
continues to move ahead nicely we're in
the right direction
and um this is no time to change
policies
yes ma'am you should comment on a
pending
stock deal that's going to be taking
place in ipo in the hong kong stock
exchanges
and technology group they could raise as
much as 40 billion dollars
potentially the largest ipo in history
there have been a lot of security
national security concerns a lot of
human rights concerns
about the technology used potentially to
suppress the uyghur people
what is the administration's position on
the ant technology group ipo
i'm going to reserve comment on the deal
itself
but i will add to your question
we are examining all these deals
and publicly held companies china-based
companies
that may list on exchanges we are
examining them
with respect to transparency uh possible
fraudulent accounting
this comes from a financial working
group report
and um we've given them one year to
shape up
and get their books in order including
their um backdrop books they're
supporting papers to prove to the public
accounting board
and the sec that they are safe
for american investors uh with whole
comment on that particular
yeah today in california
the governor issued an executive order
designed to move the state to the point
where there will be no
gas powered vehicles sold by 2035.
what do you make of this move that's
taking place in california
do you expect it to um to spread around
the country what are the politic
of the economic ramifications i don't
expect it to spread with respect to
governor
know some of them i know it just seems
like a very extreme position i don't
know how you get there
i'll have a look at the proposal if
there's more detail meat on the bones
i don't see this happening elsewhere uh
i don't think we should be
taking any steps to get rid of fossil
fuels for example
and by the way there should be consumer
choice for all automobiles and that
includes electric automobiles
but i have to look at the governor's
proposal um it just sounds very extreme
to me i don't know how you do it
larry um do you think that the fight now
over the supreme court nominee is going
to have a
major impact on the possibility to get
ppp extended
and what impact will that have on the
economy if for example
aid for airlines does not get extended
in october you know
it it doesn't have to interfere i mean
you can walk and chew gum at the same
time they operate on different lanes
legislatively so i guess that's my
we would like very much to help the
airlines we've told them that you can't
run a healthy economy
without the airline channel and we'll
see what has to be done there
with respect to possible legislation or
even possibly with respect to executive
administrative action we will take a
look on that
again you've heard me say i don't think
this
recovery right now is dependent on an
additional assistance package
but there are a number of targeted areas
in the package
including airlines most particularly
small business loans
and getting back to school that i think
would be a big help
and i just don't see if you can have
agreement on four or five or six
measures which is what's been happening
even though you don't get the whole deal
why not do it it'll help americans uh
move ahead
in terms of recovery last one you think
that we need another broad stimulus
package
or do you think do we think do you think
the us needs another broad
stimulus package or do you favor sort of
a heart
type measures like on airlines for
instance yeah i i think i would say to
you
uh sensible targeted measures might be
very helpful
i don't think we need another gigantic
multi-trillion dollar
package and as i say you know the latest
numbers coming in
are looking very good the v-shape
recovery i mean
the atlanta fed gdp now model is showing
over 30 percent growth in the third
quarter
uh the blue chip forecasters are well
over 20 percent
uh our view has been 20 plus uh we'll
see we'll get that number
uh in due course um i'm just saying
let's be smart
about some of these assistance measures
thank you
haley is the president spoken in the
family of rihanna taylor
is that a yes
you